hello this is swype on the show this
week we go back to the future as reality
catches up with section we meet one of
the writers behind the famous trilogy
and robotics and supercars how we might
be traveling in the future hello and
welcome to swipe from a familiar setting
if you're a fan of back to the future
this is a reconstruction of the cafe you
see in the second film from the
franchise we're here because you can't
excel to notice this week has been a
special one for time travel enthusiasts
October the 21st 2015 was the day marty
and doc travel do which is why stew has
been looking at what the film got right
and one inventions we're still waiting
for even if you're not a huge fan of
back to the future you can't deny that
flying cars hoverboards and self tying
shoes helped shape our collective vision
of the future these images still haven't
lost their power even if the date shown
in the movie is now past October 21st
2015 but Bob Gale and Robert Zemeckis
were seeking to entertain rather than
predict when they wrote their famous
trilogy in the 1980s we did a lot of
research of course but we also wanted to
present a future that was fun we didn't
want to do the blade runner future we
did want to do everybody has their head
shaved and wears a uniform and nobody
smiles there's a comedy the filmmakers
vision of the future did contain some
outlandish elements but they also got a
lot of things right what kinds of tech
would we see then if we punch the year
2045 into Doc Brown's DeLorean almost
certainly will have colonies on Mars
probably would be mining things like
helium-3 on the moon helium-3 is a sort
of a mineral I think we'll start looking
what we call humanity to or human 2.0
which is really breaking away from the
notion that our bodies are a given and
will have things like telesco
big eyes which can be introduced a
20-minute procedure untold so I think
it's to do with that 3d printed organs
the technology that will become
commonplace in 30 years time is already
being developed now and films have an
important role to play in showing us
what's to come if we think back to
slightly older films if you look at
something like Blade Runner for instance
then we have digital signage in there
and that's a really iconic scene from
the film and we use digital signage all
the time now audience is now are wanting
to see stuff that is futuristic but
isn't so far-fetched it's not believable
if you're hungry for the future now
though you might have quite a wait
before we see Marty McFly's version of
2015 stuart duggan sky knees you're
watching swype still to come how the
tech that makes these supercars possible
could influence our future but first
here's our round-up of some of this
week's other tech news apple news has
launched in the UK the service takes
articles from different sources
including Sky News and puts them into
one app a new type of luggage smashed
its crowdfunding target amount in less
than 24 hours when it launched on
kickstarter zero features an inbuilt
battery with USB ports for charging
devices while on the move it's also got
a location tracker so you always know
where it is and here's another
Kickstarter project doing well it's a
torch that's powered by you lumen works
when you touch it's thermoelectric
generator so it never needs batteries
it's developer says the torch is just
the first step in his research into
green energy sources remember this
little guy of course you do the modern
way to play classic cycle coming up in
our games review now about those
supercars I mentioned earlier they might
not have flux capacitors but they could
have implications for how we travel in
the future earlier I caught up with Mark
from Enki this is aki overdrive it's a
robotic racing set we just launched it
in the UK about two weeks ago we just
started the game in one of the
things you'll see is how the cars they
drive really slowly and they quickly map
out what the track looks like they
learned pretty slowly for erasing it's
just doing a lineup lat so here they
figured out exactly where what they're
doing reading the track now that's right
now what I doing that so each car has a
little tiny camera sensor on the bottom
and as they drive that camera sensor
looks down it sees little bits of
information in the road that tells it
where each of the vehicles are all right
so each of the cars they just
automatically came up to the starting
line will start the match here and it
will be three two one get ready and
you're going to use your left thumb to
slide up and go fast okay there you go
all right these are the race 2 45 laps
and these are little smart phone
controls that's right so we're remote
controlling two of the cars and the
third car is actually an AI control
character yeah okay so the green one is
a robotic aione now can you imagine in
the future seeing much more of this kind
of technology like artificial
intelligence controlling cars
controlling things in our homes much
more mainstream what do you think yeah i
mean we're trying to take a lot of the
advanced science that you see in
research labs and put it into consumer
products that you can buy for maybe a
couple hundred pounds do you hope to see
more kind of games that are less
expensive more accessible i think so
much of what we're doing can be applied
to other types of consumer robotic
applications a lot i think there's a lot
of opportunities for robots around the
home health care even in manufacturing
yeah do you think you'll see these in
hospitals one day oh absolutely you're
already seeing a lot of robots in
hospitals right now bringing drugs to
different patients you know carrying
things around will they be able to read
the tracks read the hospital corridors
maybe the due to build a smart robot you
always need to know where you are and
robots typically have some sort of
sensor that can figure out where it is
in the world times again our games fix
now and with all the back to the future
events going on we thought we'd take a
look at what games
marty mcfly might have enjoyed playing
back in the 80s is Lucy probably one of
the most famous games of all time is
pac-man made by Midway and namco from
1980 it was really famous arcade game so
think about it at the time every all the
arcades are sort of dominated by space
invaders you know asteroid and then pack
man came along and it's one of these
games that is what kind of cultural
touchstone really because it's still
very much a part of gaming these days
it's very recognizable everyone else how
to play pac-man pac-man it's very it's a
very simplistic game you know you
players because man you have to go
around collecting all a little all the
little dots you grab a power pellet you
can eat the ghosts that chasing you and
you basically have to eat all the dogs
in clear off and go on to the next stage
and collect things like keys and
cherries and all this stuff can play on
pretty much every platform available but
it's really found its home on iOS so you
can just sort of go to the App Store go
to Google Play the fine pac-man you can
play it even so a few years ago there
was like this home resurgence a of
arcade games so you could have like a
little joystick and play and pac-man was
always the one that we came with so
pac-man's going nowhere 1984 we got
Tetris it's a Russian puzzle game that
has its frequently called one of the
best games of all time and to be honest
it is again like pac-man it's a cultural
milestone everyone knows Tetris everyone
knows how to play Tetris everyone knows
the theme from Tetris and again it's on
pretty much every single gaming platform
there is last year you soft brought it
out on pretty much every every gaming
device so Nintendo 3ds visa pc xbox one
playstation 4 if you want to play Tetris
you can play Tetris I mean it's
everywhere it's so universally
accessible people immediately understand
and it's it's just really fun and it's
also one of those games where if you
play it and you fail it's like just one
more just one more I think that's the
source of the beauty of Tetris it is
said that's just one more game and
that's why it's still very popular
1988 gave us altered beast so again
starting life in an arcade found it's a
phone its way onto home consoles like
the Mega Drive so you play as a fallen
hero fallen soldier and you're
resurrected by Zeus the king of the gods
to rescue his daughter Athena and in
order to do that he lets you sort of be
the more the more you kill you kind of
and you can find power-ups you can sort
of transform into this half-man
half-beast like a werewolf is the
classic one that everyone sees and like
on the box on everything and you fight
your way through all these kind of
ancient Greek enemies like beasts and
things you can play it now on the Sega
Megadrive collection like Xbox Live
PlayStation Network they all have sort
of i think it's the Mega Drive version
that they've got so you can't play it
nowadays it's a game this it's fun to
play it's sort of like arts like a
reminiscing of the old arcade games but
it's not you know it's not a brilliant
game but it's still fun to revisit
well that's it for this week but take a
look at Sky News on mobile and I've have
for some bonus features from this week's
episode including an interview with a
man who has a back to the future
delorean and we meet Marty and Doc the
look-alikes the United sidebar by